that Chairman Jerry Nadler of the
Judiciary Committee on the house side
has decided to subpoena
lanessa penis scuse me asked for
documents from 81 people entities and
agencies with any possible link to
President Trump and just really trying
to pick apart his finances and his
presidency and this is a lot it's 81
entities Murray is this over the top I
don't think so
I think that explain yourself it Jerry
Nadler put together a list of people
that there seemed to be a purpose behind
each of the entities or people and this
is the role of oversight this is you
know I worked in 81 I worked in an
administration that had hundreds of
thousands of pages of documents
requested and subpoenaed from the
executive branch when Republicans were
in charge that's how oversight works and
if there's no problem they will submit
the documents and everything will just
continue but they're there looking to
answer real questions that have arisen
through several years of the
administration not telling the truth
about everything from ties to Russia
to whether Donald Trump paid off stormy
Daniels we now have proof he did while
in office part of the problem here is
they haven't told the truth about these
but if we have if we have those answers
now Jesse then why drag these people
through it again because it's political
warfare Steve Bannon said it best at
CPAC in 2017 he said you think the
Democrats are gonna give up peacefully
it's gonna be street fighting till the
day he's out and that's what you're
seeing they're gonna use everything in
their arsenal
I heard they actually subpoenaed the
chef that makes the taco bowls over at
Trump Tower that's how dirty they're
getting Ivanka is gonna go Ivanka is
getting subpoenaed Don jr. could you
imagine Don jr. and a hearing live oh
yeah they're gonna take that but the
broadcast networks are gonna take that
it's gonna be an amazing piece of
television and at the end I don't see
how the Democrats look good it's revenge
politics because Hillary lost the only
thing Trump obstructed was Hillary
getting into the White House and I
remember when the Republicans had the
gavel and they started issuing subpoenas
and you know what Obama officials did
they got censured they shredded
documents they retired they lied they
took the fifth and you know what the
media did
they said you guys are overreaching this
is a conspiracy theory but then when the
Democrats have the gavel they're just as
bloodthirsty we have about less than a
minute left guns we took that speech
your thoughts on this Greg too much is
it going to come back to her yes because
you can tell even lovely Murray is
revealing a little bit too much Glee in
this and I'm always suspected the Glee
Glee reveals an over overreach that
you're kind of enjoying it too much and
that this will never end
that one investigation will lead to
another and all of these actions these
investigations are two dead in the pain
of 2016 that's what this is about
they keep trying to fight a different
drug and either none of these drugs are
working first the drug was collusion
that didn't work then you had covington
that was quote that was a drug Kavanagh
was a drug Smollett was a drug the
BuzzFeed bombshell among all the other
bombshells were drugs but none of these
street drugs are taking away the pain of
2016 so they can't stop taking a quick
word
just a reminder to the Democrats that
desperation is the world's worst cologne
because that's what this this smells of
they don't expect anything to come out
of the Muller report and I've said this
for months and months and months their
focus is to merely embarrass President
Trump and anyone who has ever been close
to him or work for him they're using the
New York Times story that went splat
that nobody read last October as a road
map they just want to embarrass it
they're really mad that that story
didn't get picked up anywhere else just
it's I think I might run for president
because I don't have like 80 friends
most you're gonna like be able to
investigate three people will be in jail
shame